so if you're thinking about starting
YouTube in 2024 maybe trying to revive
your Channel or just scale your channel
in this video I'm going to be talking
about seven tips right up front here
that are going to help you come up with
better video ideas to cut through the
noise and all the competition let's face
it YouTube has more videos being posted
every day than ever before and so how do
you find topics and angles to cut
through the noise I want to share seven
things with you so number one is
audience research
one of the most important things to
understand is who is your target
audience and then you want to start
asking like what is it they really want
what are the demographics of your target
audience what are the psychographics of
your target audience I would argue in
2024 psychographics are a lot more
important demographics are going to be
age ethnicity and it's powerful to get
clear that you know my channels for Gen
X and Baby Boomers um females
that um are maybe of this skin type or
hair color if it was makeup or beauty
you know you started getting
specifically maybe some demographic type
of thing but psychographics what other
channels do they follow what are they
into what are the kind of groups they
follow like ways of thinking like do
they have political opinions do they
have religious opinions that'd be like
the psychographic so so thinking about
audience research and the mistake that
like most creators make is they don't
really have a clear audience or they
think they it's like two words like uh
it's like a channel for women you're
like okay bro like you might want to go
a little bit deeper and so uh audience
research is kind of a first layer of
really getting to understand your
audience this can go through asking
questions um and there's all kinds of
layers we could go into but for time
sake let's hit number two now keyword
research keyword research is the second
one this would be where we're actually
using tools like vid IQ and we go
not just find keywords which would be
like the search phrases a key word would
be like the word diet a keyword phrase
would be like best diet for women over
40 it's a whole phrase but that is a
keyword phrase then your question is how
much search volume per month does this
topic does this keyword phrase have and
so the powerful thing about actually
doing keyword research is you're also
now going to look for data in fact every
one of these you could have data because
you could have data about what's
happening with Gen X women you know
what's happening with genz youth pastors
like knowing your audience but then
keyword research is you're looking for
specific Search terms like how many
people are searching for this a month
and that's going to give you feedback of
what video you should make next now
another layer could be topic research
and the difference there would be okay
keyword research May point you to
there's a lot of interest
in kids ministry ideas for
five-year-olds or for a particular age
age range you're like oh wow there's
like a thousand people a month or
thousands of people a month searching
for that but then the conclusion after
that isn't that you're G to make that
exact video what it's actually going to
lead you to is a topic so some people
say keyword research is dead and they're
wrong but some people would say okay
it's less about keyword research but
where I would agree with them is like
it's not that it's less about keyword
research it's that it's about
understanding what are people really
looking for what are they interested in
what are they searching for and then
following that path of breadcrumbs to
maybe a topic that isn't so literally a
keyword but that becomes a powerful
topic for your next video and so that's
kind of the difference it's like you're
you're actually just kind of sourcing
topics there's we could talk about a
hundred different strategies for doing
that but uh you're finding what are the
best topics and again out of your next
500 video ideas not that you got 500 but
out of not that I know how to select the
right camera angle but out of your next
you know what what what are your next 10
videos what are your next 100 videos a
lot of times people make videos that
just aren't that great and I'm not even
too titling thumbnail and content I'm
like the topic itself is just I wouldn't
have made that next I probably wouldn't
even made that maybe ever like I like
find a better topic and so the powerful
thing about doing your research first
why we would say research before you
press record is so that you're better
positioned uh to get better results now
Community questions this would be where
you uh start listening the best content
creators are the best audience listeners
I think one of the biggest mistakes that
happens and I know we get busy and if
you're a parent like me or you're in
school or something you know I got a
three-year-old and a one-year-old just
like trying to get the checklist off of
the day done it's hard enough isn't it
like we're just trying to survive out
here like we're just trying to trying to
make it and so the to like the must do
list is like I got to shoot the video
and I got to plan the video and I got to
upload it and then I gotta put the trash
and recycling out tonight and then I
gotta pick up my parents from the
airport you know you just think about
you're just trying to survive and so
what can fall to the Wayside is engaging
in comments reading comments and really
deeply engaging in the community because
in a way nobody would know if you didn't
do it you know like you could get away
like you still posted a video you still
put your content out there but a lot of
times where creators results start going
downhill is because there becomes a
widening gap between where they're at
and the connection with the actual
Community reading comments getting
feedback like if I'm real transparent
with you like sometimes I think even on
our own team we can sometimes get a
little bit on the YouTube comments
because it's hard to keep up with them
too there's a lot of them where we want
to read comments on every video and
sometimes listen to the critiques the
feedback the pain points people saying
like I didn't fully understand that and
that gives you insight into the next
move so the better we listen the more we
connect in the comments the more we
listen now your objection might be Sean
I'm brand new I don't even get comments
yet I'm not going to let you off the
hook this is the coffee with candle show
man I got my Colombia press
Coffee Roasters Watermelon candy
cantaloupe guava are the notes on this
blend if you were interested in picking
it up linkoln I'm just kidding I'm
trying to get a coffee sponsor not
really I suppose but I guess the coffee
with kennel show should have a coffee
sponsor but I'm not going to let you off
the
hook if you would say I don't get any
comments yet because if you've done
audience research that means you know
who your target audience is that means
you should know where they hang out and
where they are comment and the YouTube
channels they are watching and where
they are engaging in the Reddit threads
or Facebook groups or Discord groups and
you should be an active participant in
those communities so in doing so there's
absolutely Zer zero excuse for why you
couldn't get audience insights so you
could be making videos based on the
questions that are being posted in the
comment sections of your competitor's
[Laughter]
Channel let's go to number five okay
number five Trend analysis so this would
be tools like Google Trends is something
trending up is it trending down and you
want to have a steady resource or a
steady flow of what's trending coming
your way this I suppose is kind of a
skill set and it's a muscle you develop
over time but it always surprises me
when someone's in a particular industry
like like they're in parenting or their
YouTube channels about parenting and
they're unaware of the top five to 10
blogs written blogs in parenting they
don't know the top 5 to 10 podcasts
about parenting they're not following
the top 5 to 10 Instagram accounts about
the latest trends or psychology and
parenting they're not reading like like
you got to be in your industry so like
when I say trends like you want to be in
your industry actually living it
consuming it even if you're not flying
to the conferences and events why aren't
you looking at the Recaps online so why
aren't you like really actually in the
trends but then also you should be
thinking about macro trend friends as a
side note two of the big strategies we
teach inside of uh video ranking Academy
are uh fullon course and where we go
deeper into these is Trend surfing and
influence surfing
and you can actually combine those under
a term that I would call culture
surfing like your awareness of what's
happening in the culture like it would
be your awareness of what's happening
this year it's an election year um I was
just thinking you know I'm going to make
a podcast about five to 10 things
content creators could learn from Donald
Trump triggered you know five to tenen
things people could learn from Joe Biden
or m Michelle Obama who's gonna run
who's gonna run for the I don't know
who's gonna run on the left uh and so
and and so equal opportunities here I
think media as far as because there's
things to learn from both sides but you
might be saying okay Sean what are you
doing that'd be culture surfing what's
happening this year man it's an election
year here in the US so so what's
happening in culture and so Trend
analysis would just be saying okay
what's trending where are things going
what's happening and and the mistake I
think people make is they're like Sean
I'm not
trendy like I'm not you know wearing the
latest I don't like I don't have a
Stanley mug how dare I not have a
Stanley on this
stream okay you know Niche Trend anybody
anybody got a Stanley out there the big
okay how dare I not have a think media
patterned custom Stanley all right
relax Trend analysis culture serving
what's happening in culture so it's it's
part of paying attention and having a
flow of information which I kind of
touched on this number six could be like
industry research industry research so
industry research again would be what is
your industry and how much time are you
spending actually looking inside of
what's happening in your industry what
are some of the newest things who are
the who are the experts in the industry
and what what is some of the newest
stuff coming from them like how many
books have you read on your topic in the
last you know three to six months like
you know your psychology Channel
parenting Channel Di and you and and I
know books might sound old school and
you're like why would I go old school
It's All Digital I've just found that
when you dig into a physical book that's
really rich in terms of the research and
the quality that's maybe even just
adjacently related to your YouTube
channel chances are you're going to have
a journal full of five to 10 next video
ideas and you're going to have just
little things popping off related to
that but again what does industry
research mean it means you're you're
paying attention to your research what
are the events what are the workshops
what are the Publications what are the
magazines what are the blogs what are
the podcasts again you go listen I
promise you you take your Niche you find
the top podcasts you go listen to like
one episode from each of them with a
journal out if you don't get a video
idea you're probably in the wrong
industry because it's because if you're
when you get aligned with where your
passion is and where a little bit of
experience is I'm not saying you have to
be an expert right but like where you've
got some experience in it then like
ideas will start popping off what I've
noticed most people don't even do a
quarter of this they barely do this at
all or a lot of times they don't really
research it all research before you
press record start coming up with better
and stronger video ideas and then start
getting more views as a result which
then finally number seven would be a
competitor analysis a competitor
analysis sometimes you know one of my
least favorite messages is in the crater
economy maybe business is everyone
quotes comparison is a thief of Joy can
we stop it I mean I know it's true but
like can we relax like that one has who
well comparison is the thief of joy like
to say comparison is the thief of joy
and the killer of creativity and I agree
with that message that message couldn't
be more powerful because if you're
comparing people and you and you feel
insignificant because of who you're
following on Instagram or they're
growing faster than me or I wish I had
like all of that could be toxic I think
the problem is though that has set so
many people up for failure and is that
you actually stopped comparing I
actually think comparison is the path to
wisdom comparison is essential for
business owners and entrepreneurs and
smart content creators
comparison is actually seeing what else
is out there in the market so you can
adapt your strategy accordingly it would
be incredibly foolish not to be studying
and analyzing the competitors novices
with you
know with hyp sens
itivity are afraid of comparing and
again if it leads you to insecurity and
all that kind of stuff I think that's
the thing to to deal with that's not
what I'm talking about and I'm not
talking about an issue of like worth
here or something I'm talking about
we're in a competitive landscape you
better be aware of some of the Dynamics
happening around you so you can
strategize accordingly so competitor
analysis is key because again in
business this is a classic one is USP
you know type that one out USP you ever
heard of it before what's it stand for
Unique selling proposition it means
you're unique angle on why you're
different how you're different how your
Channel's different hard to come up with
you might feel like oh there's nothing
original King Solomon said nothing's new
Under the Sun there's no new things
anymore okay it's tough that's how
that's why you got to work hard but you
can find something you know how many
YouTube educations people are out there
okay cool so Sean why are you different
well many reasons I think we have the
biggest faculty in terms of inside of
our group and whatnot we've got the
support and um kind of like Community
the most vibrant like group and there's
there could be things like that but if I
say what's the biggest reason we're
different is because most people are
just teaching random tactics that are
good their information is good tactic
here strategy here a few tips some good
information if you can apply that but I
nobody's got a system like one of the
things that makes this different is you
don't rise to the level of your goals
you fall to the level of your systems so
having a system that's a repeatable
process that you can use to reach
success it makes us different like that
nobody and and here's a couple business
words for you smart business owners in
the education space they come up with
Frameworks they come up with a
proprietary process you ever heard
somebody say that before maybe not but
they come up with like oh our
proprietary process because you might
say what is it you do who what and why
what is it you do I help people grow
their YouTube channels it's not unique
there's other people who do it okay why
like how do you do it this is how we
start cutting out difference how do we
do it well we do it with what's called
our 7R think media system and nobody
else has the approach and the
methodology that we have to Growing
ranking videos creating passive income
so our how is different and then the
other level that is different it would
be our why and Simon syic said start
with why like we do it because we're
like per you know to help 1 million
purpose-- driven people create a
full-time living doing what they love
while making a difference in the world
with YouTube and with to have that
success without losing your soul I've
heard zero people say that their mission
is to help people grow their YouTube
channels and experience that success
without losing their soul that's
different and you might go oh this guy's
kind of religious I am like my faith is
huge for me I'm out of here great I mean
I'm probably we're definitely probably
not going to be a good fit we might be
incompatible you know swipe left or
right I don't know what you do on dating
apps been married too many years but um
you know swipe and find somebody else
but when you share your why that'll
resonate but what's your how what's your
how your USP your unique selling
proposition I kind of broke that down
from how we do it at think media to
encourage you to study your competitors
because you're like how do they do it
what is their way of doing it what is
their way of creating content what is
their way of doing videos what are some
things and then in light of that
analysis how can I be different that's
kind of a side quest because ultimately
here we're talking about research and
competitor analysis would also be going
to practically number one actually
knowing who your competitors are which a
lot of people haven't even taken the
time to really think about that doing
this would be market research you're
you're you're doing a competitive an
analysis you wouldn't open up a
restaurant in a city without seeing what
other restaurants in the city what other
taco shops are there if you hadn't maybe
you would and that's the problem is you
didn't actually research ahead is the
city growing or dying is there new
developments are people moving there is
the is the market growing um what what
are the demographics in the city would
there be people interested in tacos I am
interested in tacos you got a taco I'm
starving right now is there people and
then what locations where what are the
traffic patterns like where should we
open it oh this this place for lease is
on discount well maybe there's a reason
it's on discount because nobody goes to
that side of town or you didn't realize
that someone just got stabbed over there
and that one street over it's a little
sketch so nobody actually even though if
the tacos are good people don't want to
risk their life to go to that part of
town competitor analysis looking ahead
so you're looking at okay what on other
people's channels um what are maybe some
of their top videos their top topics
what are some things I can learn there
what are something that's maybe proven
to get views that I could do a unique
spin on that'd be competitor analysis so
again we cover this deeper uh in other
places but I hope those are valuable
which one do you like best is any of
these new to you have have you done any
of these before and can you add any
value uh on the replay uh to maybe some
topics or tools you use because this is
a community right so here on our think
media podcast Channel and we do the
coffee with canel show check out the
comment section because iron sharpens
iron so you know which of these do you
like best is there any tools you use to
do any of these did are any of these a
aha moment did any of these stand out to
you let me know if you enjoyed this
podcast and are ready for some deep dive
YouTube strategy just go to think
masterclass.com to get access to my 1eh
hour OnDemand YouTube strategy class
you'll be looking over my shoulder as I
share my best tips and you can watch it
on Demand right now at think
masterclass.com